[Musique]
nous sommes et illhaeusern
comme vous vous en souvenez sûrement la
commune a connu d'importantes
inondations au mois de janvier lors de
la crue décennale de lille
pas de dégâts majeurs cependant ce
secteur sensible et surveiller comme le
lait sur le feu par le service rivière
et barrages du conseil départemental
ici les inondations on y est préparé on
a connu une forte période de crue début
janvier
alors la raison principale c'est que
donc cette rivière la fecht qui était
derrière moi bah se jette dans l'île qui
passe par idw interne et donc que les
deux rivières montant cru donc
inévitablement c'est un secteur ici qui
est qui est fortement touchée donc que
lors de ces périodes là sur l'ensemble
du haut rhin ce sont environ 1000 km de
rivières qui sont gérés par le conseil
départemental
une quinzaine de personnes de la
direction de l'environnement leur sont
dévolues ainsi qu'à la gestion des
nombreux ouvrages qui les parcelles sur
ces rivières se trouve à peu près 500
ouvrages aussi comme celui que nous
voyons ici également donc qui est un
avantage
et puis dans les 250 km de digues
c'est en gros 170 millions d'euros qui
avaient été investis sur ces différents
dispositifs sur les trente dernières
années le département gère dix barrages
sur son territoire des ouvrages d'art
situé bien en amont de la rivière sont
les premiers outils de gestion dudit ici
donc un amont de la vallée de la fecht
il y a le lac des truites le lac vert
lights veilleurs et dechy street que
nous pouvons donc nous nous pouvons
faire des actions qui nous permettent de
stocker l'eau donc pendant la période
des crues c'est à dire en hiver et au
printemps et à l'averse de céder stocker
l'eau pour la porter à la rivière en été
pendant la période d'étiage et donc pour
assurer la qualité aquatique un dock de
la rivière en été et en automne
en aval au fil de la rivière sont
installés ces dispositifs de vannage ici
celui de guémar prédit leiser vous voyez
il ya une une vanne qui est fermée tout
à fait à droite celle du milieu quand la
crue monte au la ferme également et ça
permet donc à l'eau de partir par un
canal qui est à gauche ici vers des
champs d'inondation et donc de réduire
sensiblement le débit le débit du cours
d'eau
nous avons un deuxième à nages qui est
situé un peu plus haut à ostheim à et
donc c'est de ces deux dispositifs nous
permettent de bien régulé le volume et
le débit donc delà de la rivière enfin
il arrive que malgré tous ces
équipements le débit ne puisse être
contenue
le niveau monte les dykes son talent le
dernier rempart pour empêcher
inondations des routes et des villages
cette digue permet de protéger à la fois
la route départementale qui est qui est
juste à côté
les habitations et donc une zone
d'activité qui est un petit peu plus loi
ainsi que des anciens hangars tonka à
tabac alors ici à des gros travaux qui
ont été réalisés
il y a deux ans trois ans peut-être avec
donc la pose de fascines na
en bas d'une queue de la digue pour
consolider donc le talus et la
plantation donc deux de végétaux ici
c'est des sols qui permettent aussi de
retenue de retenir donc le talus qui est
qui est maintenant en pente plus douce
et également si le service barrages et
riviera bien sûr pour objectif de
protéger les habitants de la montée des
eaux
ce n'est pas la seule mission de cette
entité départementale
quand on s'occupe de gestion de l'eau on
s'occupe aussi d'environnement et
parfois la nature a besoin d'un petit
coup de main
là on est exactement à une nouvelle
confluence entre les strings barré la
fecht un convoi très bien sur le plan
avant on avait la confluence à ce niveau
là et puis maintenant on a recréé des
méandres là et on a cette nouvelle
confluence ici sur le plan ça permet de
redonner un petit peu de longueur au
cours d'eau de recréer des méandres et
puis de recréer une zone humide qui est
propice à l'installation des espèces
végétales et animales donc on a par
exemple créé une catiche à loutre ou les
loutres peuvent donc se réinstaller on a
remarqué par exemple qu'il y a de
nouveau des traces de castor et c'est
donc ça signifie que le travail qui a
été fait de renaturation porte ses
fruits
alors il ya aussi tout un travail par
rapport aux passes à poissons plus
généralement de de continuité du cours
d'eau pour la traversée des espèces donc
les poissons migrateurs
donc on travaille sur sur ce plan là au
niveau de tous les cours d'eau de notre
département
en plus de faire le bonheur des castors
ce nouveau méandres permet lui aussi de
contenir la montée des eaux
enfin malheureusement il ne faudra pas
trop compter sur les loutres pour vous
avertir en cas d'inondation heureusement
cela le département l'avait prévu c'est
pour rendre l'information accessible à
tous en temps réel que le site info géo
68 a été mise en ligne
donc c'est un site qui fait de la
prévision hydrologiques or c'est à dire
qu on a une carte avec l'ensemble des
cours d'eau du département
et on a des petites gouttes sur cette
carte qui représente une station où on
peut voir le débit de la rivière
donc c'est très utile lors des crues
puisqu'on cliquant simplement sur la
petite goutte de vote de la commune
concernée on peut regarder le débit à
venir et donc les dix prochains jours de
dos dans le dans le cours d'eau ça nous
permet à nous d'anticiper aux communes
d'avoir un l'information en temps réel
est de pouvoir anticiper justement pour
déplacer les engins à des endroits
appropriés pour pour la crue à jour de
quoi vous assurer de ne pas vous
réveiller les pieds dans l'eau